le 9 juin 1798 les vaisseaux de l'armée
d'orient portant dix milles marins plus
de 33000 soldats et une pléiade de
savants bouillon face de laval est le
principal port de l'île de malte en
méditerranée malte occupe une position
stratégique et il ne faut pas qu'elles
servent aux anglais c'est la raison qui
a décidé bonaparte à conquérir l'île en
quelques heures c'est chose faite
il a suffi que l'afrique commence a
canonné l'effort pour que le grand
maître de l'ordre jette le gant et
abandonne l'île aux français
bonaparte débarque le 12 juin vers 13h
fait le tour des remparts et visites
l'effort et il vient de chasser à jamais
de lille les chevaliers de l'ordre de
malte qui s'y étaient installés en 1530
nous sommes bien heureux dira le général
caffarelli qu'il y ait eu quelqu'un dans
la place pour nous ouvrir les portes
dans merschen street la rue principale
de la valette le palais par idiot où
séjourna bonaparte
c'est aujourd'hui le ministère des
affaires étrangères dc il organise à sa
conquête
l'escadre et ravitaillé et une dernier
don de 3000 hommes est installé sous les
ordres du général vos bois dans le
bureau du ministre des affaires
étrangères une plaque à rappelle que
cette pièce fut la chambre de bonaparte
du 12 au 18 juin
à l'époque les français décidèrent de
saisir l'or et l'argent des églises
appartenant à l'ordre de malte à
l'exception des objets du culte
alors pour soustraire à la réquisition
c'est gris d'argent elles furent peints
en noir un camouflage dont il reste
encore quelques traces
m dina autrefois site avec ya au centre
de l'île
le clocher de l'église des carmélites
donna le signal de l'émeute des 2 et 3
septembre
1798 à deux pas cette maison où le
capitaine masson assailli par la
populace révolte et se réfugia on le
défenestrer
il fut tué sur le coup nous sommes en
phase de malte sur l'île de gozo où
débarquent à la division renier le fort
chambre est construit en 1749 fut l'un
des rares points de résistance aux
troupes françaises sentinelles du temps
qui passe le fort est abandonné depuis
longtemps et la nature a repris ses
droits
assiégés par les anglais le général vos
voix résiste à deux ans avant de mettre
bas les armes
malte passa sous la coupe des
britanniques pour de très longues années
le 18 juin l'escadre française repris la
mer soldats vous allez entreprendre une
conquête dont les effets sur la
civilisation et le commerce du monde
sont incalculables
les destins sont pour nous bonaparte ne
croyait pas si bien dire
c'est vrai qu'il a fallu une chance
incroyable pour échapper à la croisière
anglet et le 1er juillet 1798
alexandrie est en vue
nous marchons ici à l'endroit exact où
le général bonaparte a foulé la terre
d'egypte
c'était dans la nuit du 1er au 2 juillet
1798 et sans attendre son intérêt ni ses
chevaux le général a décidé de marcher
tout de suite sur la ville d'alexandrie
vous retrancher derrière leurs murailles
turcs et arabes font un feu bien nourrie
pleyber à la tête de ces hommes montent
à l'assaut des fortifications et reçoit
une balle en plein front
mais l'alsacien à la tête solide et leur
échappera réfugier dans le fort de keith
b les défenseurs demande grâce en fin de
matinée la ville est prise
aujourd'hui kate bay est un musée lefort
sert d'écrin aux objets récupérés dans
les entrailles du vaisseau amiral
lorient coulé à aboukir
aboukir c'était une vingtaine de
kilomètres d'alexandrie ici le 1er août
1798 l'amiral nelson surpris les
français entre deux feux à la tombée de
la nuit tout va mal très mal et vers 22h
lorient explose dans un immense fracas
tout est joué notre flotte et détruit au
trois quarts l'armée d'orient est
prisonnière de sa conquête
lorsque les français arrivent à
alexandrie on compte à peine dix mille
habitants
aujourd'hui la ville rêvée par alexandre
le grand ensemble macadamisé avec les
ruines pulvérisé 2000 cité bonaparte
ordonna que les quarante soldats tombés
lors des combats soit enterrée au pied
de la célèbre colonne de pompey que
vivant denon dessina et toute l'armée
défilé aux cris de vive la république
à l'époque hors de la ville la colonne
de pompey est aujourd'hui étranglé
victime d'une urbanisation galopante
alex henry pacifié l'armée se met en
marche pour affronter le désert on a vu
les soldats mourir de soif d'inanition
de chaleur notre voyant les souffrances
de leurs camarades se brûler la cervelle
17 jours d'enfer avant d'atteindre le
nil
ici près du bourg de ram a nié les
hommes s'y précipitent tout habillé pour
étancher leur soif
voilà ce qu'est devenu le champ de
bataille du 21 juillet 1798 le caire
forte c'est 15 millions d'habitants
n'arrête pas d'un excès le désert à
l'époque le sable aller jusque sur les
bords du nil c'est à dire à une douzaine
de kilomètres d'ici là où les soldats de
bonaparte se battaient donc ces derniers
ont très bien vu qu'ils optent képhren
et mykérinos d'où le nom donné à ce
combat de légende
la bataille des pyramides la retirer vos
mii la mitraille les soldats tirent à
bout portant
la bravoure inutile des cavaliers
mamelouks se brise contre un mur d'acier
soldats du haut de ces pyramides
quarante siècles vous content la phrase
est célèbre en tout cas bonaparte exulte
la bataille des pyramides scelle le sort
de l'egypte le pays est à lui
la citadelle du caire fortifiée dès le
douzième siècle
afin de protéger le pays des attaques
des croisés c'était le domaine réservé
des mamelouks et c'est une vraie ville
hôte que les français découvrent à leur
arrivée fin septembre 98 les habitants
furent expulsés et on y installa
garnison et des canons des canons qui
servira mois plus tard lors de la
révolte du caire dominant la ville ce
canon d'opérette fait face à la mosquée
du sultan hassan les pièces françaises
étaient installés au même endroit
khabar
le mur de la mosquée porte encore les
traces de nos boulet tiré fin octobre 98
pour mater les meutes 300 français et
quatre mille insurgés perdirent la vie
lors de ses 48 heures de violences
la répression fut jugée sévère mais
équitable bonaparte y gagne un surnom le
sultan kébir en français le sultan juste
c'est dans le quartier populaire dit
tulum que se cache la rue elle mange
longe fut le premier président de
l'institut d'égypte créé par bonaparte
l'institut s'était donné pour mission
l'étude du pays bien sûr mais aussi la
propagation des lumières en egypte mais
au moins d'août 98 les savants planchent
sur des questions plus pratiques telles
que le remplacement du houblon dans la
fabrication de la bière ou encore
l'amélioration des fours utilisés par
l'armée
cette maison dite d'ibrahim el scénarii
l as one est le dernier vestige de
l'institut d'égypte à l'époque elle
servait de musées bibliothèques est
aujourd'hui à l'abandon
en plein coeur du vieux caire le temps
semble retenir son souffle
cette superbe demeure ottomane le palais
moussafir cana se souvient peut-être de
ses officiers français qui la nuit venue
s'abandonnait aux mystères de l'orient
revenons un instant à la révolte du
caire d'octobre 98 avec ce tableau peint
par giraudet mais surtout avec cette
mosquée la mosquée el azhar dernier
bastion des insurgés qui fut envahi par
les troupes françaises construites en
elle offre aujourd'hui un mélange de
styles reflétant divers époque car ici
chaque souverain a tenu à laisser son
empreinte à cinq heures de route du
caire se trouve la porte entre l'afrique
et l'asie
le désert du sinaï
un lieu d'une sauvage beauté vierge des
ravages du monde moderne
c'est là au milieu d'un paysage lunaire
de montagne granitique au 6e siècle
l'empereur justinien ordonna la
construction d'un monastère forteresse
oh
les moines ont donné au coin de l'eln or
le nom de napoléon
car bonaparte en égypte pris le
monastère sous sa protection
il succède dans ce rôle à mahomet au
khalife musulmans et au sultan turc qui
tous préserver ce lieu du pillage
le haut
aujourd'hui les moines grecs orthodoxes
veille jalousement sur la plus riche
collection de manuscrits au monde après
celle du vatican et parmi ces trésors le
document détaillant les droits et les
privilèges accordés aux moines signé de
la main même de bonaparte
à
quittons le caire pour sédiments à la
poursuite des mamelouks de mourad ben et
le général desaix les rejoint début
octobre 1798 non loin du petit village
de sédiments et après plusieurs
escarmouches les mamelouks finissent par
accepter le combat
voici le champ de bataille de sédiments
entre autres se trouvaient le petit
carré français composé de 150 hommes des
chasseurs de la 20e légère commandée par
le capitaine valette le capitaine
valette est un brave homme intrépide
jusqu'à l'extrême
il ordonna à ses soldats de nourrir le
feu qui a dit pas
la salve des français fut meurtrière
bien sûr mais pas suffisante pour
arrêter la cavalerie mamelouks lancés à
plein galop le carré fut enfoncé les
hommes furent massacrés car un cavalier
mamelouks manie le sabre mieux que
quiconque
cet épisode est le seul dans toute la
conquête de l'egypte où la cavalerie
orientale réussi à enfoncer un carré
français un épisode dramatique mais qui
ne change pas le cours de la bataille le
grand carré français lui forte d'environ
3000 hommes marchaient au pas de charge
sur les positions des mamelouks et
contraint mourad bay à s'enfuir une
nouvelle fois dans le désert la victoire
de ses dément pour le général desaix est
importante car non seulement elle lui
donne le contrôle sur la province du
fayoum mais en plus elle ouvre les
portes de la conquête de la haute egypte
dans cette expédition les militaires ne
sont pas seuls avec eux des savants de
l'institut d'égypte dont vivant denon
ici à l'oeuvre
je n'aurais point d'expression pour
rendre ce que j'éprouvais écrit-il
devant denderah en janvier 1799
il faut dire que le remarquable état de
conservation du temple suscita
l'admiration de toute l'armée
voici la façade avec cette tête à
oreille de vache telle qu'elle fut
dessiné à l'époque
et voilà ce qu'il en reste
sur la terrasse du temple d'atr dominant
la vallée et endroit de choix pour
monter la garde
on peut encore lire gravé dans la pierre
le nom de louis guybourg carabiniers à
la 21e légère
longeant le nil s'enfonçant toujours
plus au sud le 26 janvier 1799 à 9
heures du matin les français
découvrirent thèbes spontanément les
hommes formés relais rang et
présentèrent les armes de ses écrits à
bonaparte gardant le temple de louxor il
y a deux obélisques d'une taille et d'un
fini qui font qu'aucun de ceux de roms
de leur est comparable
transporté à paris il dit serait bien
extraordinaire
le voeu du général desaix fut réalisé 35
ans plus tard offert par l'egypte le
belize que manquantes trône place de la
concorde à paris
cette forêt de colonne c'est la salle
hypostyle du temple de karnak vivant
denon en marge de ces dessins écrit si
les égyptiens dans le reste de cet
édifice nous paraissent des géants dans
cette dernière production
ce sont des génies
sur la paroi latérale du temple d'amon
on distingue encore l'inscription
laissées par l'armée d'orient à propos
de la latitude et la longitude des
temples en haute egypte
pour les anciens égyptiens naviguer vers
l'ouest et gagner la terre de vie pour
nous c'est rejoindre la rive des morts
sentinelle de l'éternité les deux
colosses de memnon veille au repos des
pharaons un bruyant silence c'est la
vallée des rois telle qu'elle s'est
offerte aux regards des français
les gardiens du temple de médine et à
bout semble sortir d'un tableaux
orientalistes ce temple n'a pas échappé
à la curiosité des membres de l'institut
d'égypte
eux aussi ont admiré les couleurs
originales dont le temps n'est pas venu
à bout
poussant toujours les mamelouks devant
lui fin janvier 1799 de ces antres à
esneux l'ancien lato police à l'époque
le temple est enfoui dans le sable les
habitants le masque de méchantes masure
en ruine écrit vivant denon et se livre
aux usages les plus abjects jouxtant le
temple ce caravansérail hier bruissant
de vie aujourd'hui désertés
sur la rive gauche du nil à plus d'une
centaine de kilomètres de thèbes est fou
aux russes le dieu à la tête de faucon
son temple servi de cantonnement aux
soldats de 2,7 il y laissèrent de
nombreux graffitis surtout sur la
terrasse de ce temple l'un des mieux
conservés d'égypte
à côté du maître tracé la signature le
gentil ingénieurs français en 8 ghz
bourg carabiniers à la 21e légère
robert 1799 jean baptiste vérane 1799
cuvillier chasseurs vaincre ou mourir
savelli 1799
les français sont vainqueurs partout
non loin da soit l'île de filet est
l'une des plus merveilleuses surprise
qu'un voyageur puisse éprouver vivant
denon a mille fois raison
aujourd'hui les puristes parleront de
l'île de glinka c'est le nom de ce petit
île où l'on a transféré le temple en
1979 pour le sauver de la montée des
eaux du barrage
là aussi les français ont laissé leur
marque sur cette inscription on peut
lire la longitude depuis paris sous ce
portique le sculpteur castex aggravé
l'an 6 de la république le 13 mai six
d'or une armée française commandée par
bonaparte est descendu alexandrie
l'armée ayant mis vingt jours après les
mamelouks en fuite aux pyramides de
cette commande est la première division
les a poursuivies au-delà des cataractes
où il est arrivé le 13 ventôse de
l'enset les généraux de brigade daoust
friands et belliard donzelot chef de
l'état-major latournerie commandes
l'artillerie et plaire chef de la 21e
légère le treize vents chose en cette de
la république les mamelouks repoussée
derrière les cataractes l'île de filet
marque le terme du voyage pour les
hommes de 2,7 en mai 1799 toute la haute
egypte et pacifiées
le 10 février 1999
bon à part quitte le caire avec treize
mille hommes il veut empêcher les turcs
d'arriver en egypte car le sultan de
constantinople
aiguillonné par les russes et les
anglais s'est mis dans la tête de
chasser les français d'égypte sur la
route de jaffa l'armée prend d'assaut la
petite ville de ramlé ce clocher qui
domine le centre-ville c'est celui de
l'hospice saint georges
bon à part qui passe à deux nuits le 1er
et le 2 mars 1799
voici la chambre qu'il occupa sur
laquelle veillent jalousement
aujourd'hui le père edouard le supérieur
du couvent
aux murs des gravures rappelle aux
visiteurs le destin extraordinaire de ce
jeune général en chef à la poursuite de
son rêve d'orient
ce couloir qui résonna de bruits de
bottes et de cliquetis de sabre et
maintenant le domaine des oiseaux
aujourd'hui tel aviv a grignoté la côte
jusqu'aux muraille de jaffa devant cette
forteresse de pierre bonaparte envoie un
parlementaire en guise de réponse les
assiégés lui tranche la tête et la
promène au bout d'une pique sur les
remparts la fureur s'emparent à leur des
français qui investissent la ville
toute la nuit les combats font rage au
petit matin le spectacle est affreux
plus de trois mille cadavres jonchent
les ruelles de jaffa et les derniers des
pensions qui se rendent seront tous
passés par les armes
et puis la peste la terrible peste
éclate avec une virulence extrême témoin
d'une scène d'anthologie l'hôpital
français rue pasteur est toujours debout
bonaparte est venu ici visiter ces
soldats que la maladie à bas des jeunes
est le médecin chef de l'armée qui
l'accompagnent raconte le général par là
à tous et s'occupe à tous les détails il
aida aussi un infirmier a soulevé le
cadavre hideuse d' un pestiféré dont les
habits en lambeaux été souillées ce
célèbre tableau de gros exprime on ne
peut mieux la force de cette visite
aujourd'hui l'hôpital appartient à la
communauté des soeurs de saint-joseph de
l'apparition qui veulent transformer en
auberge pour pellerin
c'est une armée affaiblie par la maladie
et les garnisons laissé en arrière qui
arrive devant saint jean d'âcre
bonaparte a les yeux tournés vers
l'histoire
ce 19 mars 1799 lorsqu'il arrive en vue
de saint jean d'âcre
il faut dire que la ville est célèbre
d'alexandre le grand o croisées on
trouve même son nom dans les papyrus du
pharaon ramsès ii alors il a en face de
lui
djezzar pacha surnommé le boucher c'est
tout dire il est aidé par les anglais du
commodore sydney smith et par un
français picard de phélippeau un ancien
condisciple de bonaparte royaliste
convaincu qui a juré la mort de la
république s'est dit si du haut de la
colline napoléon c'est son nom actuel
environ à 2 kilomètres des murailles que
bonaparte dirigea le siège de la ville
pour les français la sphère est plutôt
mal engagé car la croisière anglaise a
réussi à capturer la plupart des bateaux
français qui transportait l'équipage de
sièges il va falloir faire sans grosses
pièces et puis très vite les bouley vont
commencer à manquer il fallait faire de
la récupération de boulay et demi au
risque de sa vie
chaque boule est de 12 livres par
exemple étaient payés aux soldats 15
sous le siège va durer on le sait 62
jours on ne compte pas les actes
d'héroïsme lorsqu'il fallait monter à
l'assaut des fortifications
on ne compte pas non plus les actes de
bravoure lorsqu'il fallait repousser les
turcs qui tentaient des sorties mais il
faut se rendre à l'évidence sans a
retiré deux sièges
la ville était imprenable et bonaparte
fort des nouvelles reçues d'égypte c'est
à dire le débarquement imminent d'une
armée turque décida de lever le camp
saint jean d'arc c'est une sorte de
millefeuille de pierre la cité qui
s'offre aux regards n'a que deux siècles
et n'est qu'un pâle reflet de son passé
spectaculaire elle fut construite sur
celle édifié au 12e siècle par les
croisés une ville sous la ville que les
fouilles permettent aujourd'hui de
découvrir les soldats de bonaparte n'ont
pas vu ses murailles
tirant les leçons du siège les turcs
qu'ils ont construites après le départ
des français
en revanche celle ci furent prises
d'assaut la citadelle c'était le palais
d'ahmed le boucher il abrite maintenant
un musée de l'héroïsme on peut encore
voir incrusté à jamais dans ses murs les
boules est tirée par les canons français
saint jean d'âcre semble aujourd'hui
endormi à l'image du caravansérail l um
dame en france l auberge des colonnes
que domine la fameuse tour turc au
détour d'une ruelle une plaque qui
rappelle que le major anglais oldfield
tués lors du siège fut enterrée avec les
honneurs de la guerre par les soldats
français
mais l'armée pleurera plus qu'un autre
le général caffarelli commandant le
génie de l'armée d'orient blessé au bras
et amputé il mourra de la gangrène des
tombes tout simple d'un blanc immaculé
pour ces hommes d'exception un petit
cimetière que les constructions de
l'université de saint jean d'âcre
étouffe de plus en plus nazareth le 8
avril 1799
deux mille cinq cents cavaliers turc
fonde sur les 400 hommes du général juno
bien mal leur en a pris
après cinq heures de combat les turcs
jette le gant les 106 ans mort sur le
champ de bataille
les français eux ont perdu douze hommes
les quelques blessés furent recueillis
par les pertes chrétiens si le couvent
et la basilique ont depuis été
reconstruit le père arthur au conserve
précieusement les registres de cette
année 1799
la même année le 22 avril
françois boucher je pense à ces départs
et par ici nous parisiens soldats dans
la ration offrant des français avant
avoir déçu tous les sacrements de
l'église et les volets de cette vie
c'est de dire à la vie éternelle et 2
étaient entrés dans les cimetières latin
c'est très bien ça
à dix kilomètres de nazareth dominant
orgueilleusement la plaine le mont
thabor derrière moi le mont thabor qui
fut le témoin de cette fameuse bataille
du 16 avril 1799 l'un des plus beaux
faits d'armes de toute la campagne
l'armé du pacha damas avancé pour fondre
sur les français devant les murailles de
saint jean d'âcre le général kléber et
sa division était chargé de couvrir les
abords du siège et kleber décida
d'attaquer les turcs de nuit oui mais
voilà il fait déjà jour lorsqu'il
débarque dans la plaine kléber ordonne à
ses hommes
ils sont 2500 de former deux carrés et
toute la journée ils résistent aux
assauts furieux de 25000 tueur
vingt quatre heures de l'après-midi de
critique la situation devient désespérée
heureusement le canon tonne au loin des
bonaparte qui volent secours ses frères
d'armes avec et 3000 hommes de la
division bon ils ont marché jour et nuit
en 24 heures
ils ont fait 50 km pour débarquer sur le
champ de bataille
pris entre deux feux c'en est fini de
l'armée turque à qui cette journée aura
coûté entre les morts les blessés et les
prisonniers près de 6000 hommes
les français eux ont perdu 300 personnes
entre les tués et les blessés
l'abbé d'haïfa éveillé depuis des
siècles par le monastère des carmes
lorsque bonaparte lève le siège de saint
jean d'âcre les blessés laissé aux bons
soins des moines seront massacrés par
les turcs
ils reposent tous sous cette pyramide
aux braves soldats de l'armée d'égypte
peut-on lire au pied de cette croix
forgé en 1876 par les marins français du
château renault à mi chemin entre haïfa
et jaffa les ruines de césarée ville
fortifiée par louis 9 au temps des
croisades l'armée bivouac ici le 22 mai
1799 sur le chemin du retour le chemin
du caire
le 14 juin 1799 une foule énorme fait un
triomphe à l'armée de syrie bonaparte
entre en ville par la porte bab el snarr
surnommé aussi portes de la victoire en
marchant sur un lit de palme que l'on
jette sous les pieds de sa monture c'est
ce jour là qu'on lui donnera le même
look roustan sur les treize mille hommes
partis en février à peu près 8000 sont
de retour
noyer dans un quartier populaire du sud
de la ville le cimetière latin de terre
sainte
ultime hommage à ceux qui ne revient
jamais la france
début juillet 99 la flotte anglo turc
jette langue dans la rade d'aboukir
bonaparte n'a pas de temps à perdre
lefort d'aboukir est aujourd'hui zone
interdite
il est au centre d'une base militaire
égyptienne mais le temps n'a pas effacer
les cicatrices des combats nous sommes
ici au coeur du fort d'aboutir qui fut
le témoin à 12 grandes batailles l'une
ma rétine nous avons parlé la seconde
terrestre qui se déroula le 25 juillet
quelques jours auparavant mustapha pacha
avait débarqué sur la côte égyptienne à
la tête de douze mille turcs bien décidé
à surprendre bonaparte mais ce dernier
informé se dépêcha d'accourir sur les
lieux avec eu mille de ses soldats le
combat s'est donc engagé 25 les français
ont franchi les deux gros doutes qui les
séparait de ce fort les turcs ont été
bousculés et sur les 10000 qui défendent
l esaa board for simplement 200
survécurent c'est lors de cette bataille
que le général murat fut blessé mustapha
pacha en personne lui tira une balle de
pistolet qu'il est traversé à les deux
jours est bien mûre a replica d'un
violent coup de sabre qui tranche à deux
doigts de mustapha pacha qui bien sûr
fut fait prisonnier
la bataille d'alexandrie fut la dernière
victoire de bonaparte en égypte les
nouvelles d'europe ont décidé à partir
pour la france et clic il à ses hommes
je laisse le commandement de l'armée au
général kléber
il me coûte de quitter les soldats
auxquels je suis le plus attaché
l'armée aura bientôt de mes nouvelles et
le 23 août à bord de la muire ont il
regarde s'éloigner les côtes égyptiennes
l'armée d'orient elle ne reverra la
france qu'à l'automne 1801 ayant dû
abandonner l'egypte aux anglais cette
plaque dans les murs du fort julien
rappelle que l'on fait ici une
découverte capitale
c'est au cours de travaux de
fortification du fort que le capitaine
du génie bouchard un jeune
polytechnicien de 27 ans exumas la
fameuse pierre de rosette l'importance
de cette trouvaille n'échappe pas aux
officiers
cette pierre écrivent-ils dans leur
compte rendu à l'institut d'égypte cette
pierre offre un grand intérêt pour
l'étude des caractères hiéroglyphique
peut-être en donnera-t-elle la clé
remarquable prophétie puisque en 1822
grâce à la pierre de rosette champollion
découvrait la clé des hiéroglyphes perdu
depuis quinze siècles une autre aventure
commençait
on